all right we are live for another live
reading from my book reason fulfilled by
revelation the 1930s christian
philosophy debates
in france and
we are smack dab in the middle of one of
the big pieces from the middle of the
work maurice blondel's the problem of
catholic philosophy which which was a
uh presentation at the meeting of the
associated philosophy
in 1932 and was published in lately to
philosophy the journal associated with
it
in 1933
and one of the interesting things about
this were there were letters um
blondel was in
physically not not great condition he
was nearly blind at this time and had to
work by
correspondence and he had a secretary
who would read things aloud to him and
then take dictation
so what we actually have here are four
letters
about blondel's presentation which he
had written out ahead of time so these
are people responding
to what blondel had to say
we have enrico castelli
jean devil vey
and then we have
henri guilier who's a little bit better
known and then finally the only figure
of these who's probably still well known
today joseph mara shaw
and i think there's over 20
pages of these letters and responses so
i think i'm just gonna do the first
two today in part because i'm a little
worn down it's the end of the semester
uh i just finished earlier this morning
giving a two-hour presentation about
epictetus
so i'm going to you know
cut it shorter a little bit today
so i'll just read the letters by
castelli and devil vey and then
blondel's responses to them about 10
pages
worth of text so
here is the comments of mr enrique
enrico castelli
regarding the new proceedings on the
problem of catholic philosophy that
maurice blondel presented at the session
of last november 26th i send you the
following reflections they are not an
explicit response to the questions mr
blondel raised but rather to the
problems formulated
by mr et angel song i nevertheless
believe they might help add a note to
this interesting controversy
in his inquiry about christian
philosophy's notion mr jillson noting
that the expression christian philosophy
is used frequently enough in our day
raised the problem of such a notion's
possibility observing right at the start
that certain theologians of the middle
ages exclude the possibility of such a
notion
from their point of view revelation
renders philosophical research useless
by resolving once and for all the
problem raised by critique it is this
attitude mr blondel summarizes in this
way in order to attack it
let us cultivate our garden without
letting ourselves be guided by
imagination or by pride let us leave
behind these transcendent speculations
ages of decadence take pleasure in and
which are a negation of good sense
but one objection
an
uneliminable and decisive one arises
revelation must be understood
in the second place revelation not being
total demands this critical deepening
which can even sometimes seem the
negation of common sense already pascal
had written we must judge of doctrine by
miracles we must judge of miracles by
doctrine
certainly rationalism
rationalism's objection
raised by the same jill so is more
serious
there can be christians who would be
philosophers but no christian
philosophers it is in this way that a
christian philosophy's possibility is
excluded
because philosophy dispenses with
revelation as reason dispenses with
prejudice for neo-tomism as well
the notion has no meaning
quote it is only due to its rationality
that tomism should be a philosophy and a
true philosophy the result is that if
the thomas philosophy is philosophy it
is insofar as rational not insofar as
christian
to the contrary in augustinianism the
expression seems fully justified perhaps
jillson observes because augustine's
philosophy implies man in his concrete
state that is
by including his religious life in that
state
but the thing that interests us the most
is not knowing if augustinianism
justifies more or less such a notion a
purely historical problem but rather
understanding its possibility historical
problems interest us only in a limited
way and the fact that a uh h ritter or a
stucco wrote a history of christian
philosophy does not demonstrate such a
philosophy's possibility
there is a revelation of which the
church is the guardian
revealed doctrine cannot contradict
reason for in that case we would not in
any way be able to take account of the
supernatural character of that doctrine
in fact one can recognize that character
only by resting it on sufficient reasons
if the reasons that are brought were not
sufficient that is good we would not
have good reasons to believe
that doctrine to be revealed that is if
revelation transcended our intellect it
would remain unknown
it is impossible in my opinion
to be able to hold ourselves back from
this alternative which does not however
keep faiths beginning from presupposing
grace
quote if anyone says that the ascent to
christian faith is not free but
necessarily produced by arguments of
human reason let him be anathema this is
from the defeat of the first vatican
council
the theologians repeated exertions are
rightly oriented in this sense mystery
is above reason and not contrary to
reason
still
we cannot fail to note that there are
problems that seem to justify
only the contrary thesis for example the
irrationality of mystery
in the order of divine foreknowledge
because of the contradiction that exists
between foreign knowledge and
spontaneity
hence the opportun in philosophy
hereticum essay
of pomponazi
how to resolve this conflict
a conflict that taking account
of canon 2 of davide is doubly
complicated because of the antinomy of
liberty and necessity for quote either
you see with certainty that god is
spoken or you do not see it with
certainty writes pierre russo in an
article that would merit being better
known
in the first case how can the ascent be
free in the second
how can it be legitimately certain
the dilemma simplicity should not cause
its force to be unrecognized
many actually uphold the necessity of a
blind belief preceding clear knowledge
others to the contrary advise first
examining and deepening and then
believing afterwards it is too evident
that while the former compromised
certainty the latter compromise freedom
volunteerism or intellectualism
this is not a case of closing one's eyes
there is a difficulty here in a serious
one
the motives we have for believing either
are or are not sufficient if they are
sufficient they become true and proper
reasons if they are not i repeat we do
not have sufficient reasons to believe
that the doctrine that is proposed to us
is revealed
can a solution to this difficulty be
found
let us reflect
a rigorous and earnest reasoning could
not be conclusive for a reasoning rigor
is one thing conclusiveness is another
and it could not be conclusive by
consequence of some possible errors that
are used as its base
can we rule out a more deepened study of
premises certainly not still if this is
always possible is this always easy i do
not believe
it is
the infinite number
of common senses logical assumptions
fetters the work and at times prevents
coming to a solution of the greatest
problems
on the other hand
if the restlessness ceaselessly pushing
us to the search for truth is the
indispensable condition for the
understanding of that truth all too
often alas it transforms this aid into
an obstacle
abstract logics extratemporal laws
possess value as means allowing
only his means allowing the immediate
datum to be surpassed but if the fact of
being necessary means for resolving the
vital problem of destiny
is precisely what gives the laws their
value it is also true that logical
thought cannot exist outside of the
psychic fact at least accepting plato's
doctrine that is outside of the
initiatives where that necessary element
which makes of a succession of psychic
facts a fully and consciously lived life
and not a simple and chaotic succession
of experiences
has
not yet been distinctly enough
recognized conscious life presents us
the dramatic alternative of a decisive
choice to be or not to be
to be
that is to enlarge and augment always
our consciousness of being not to be
that is to diminish ourselves to believe
wrongly that one can dilly dally the
whole length of the road force oneself
to separate life from that effort that
sets its ideal above and beyond the
present but for whose realization the
present alone is decisive because it
decides the person's future
anguishedly searching to understand
themselves people often wind up in a
complete lack of understanding a bitter
conclusion doubtless
but one that finds its reason in these
assumptions of common sense our weak
strengths do not end up eliminating
we can believe to have accomplished the
deepening and to believe it in good
faith but from that point on when the
conflict between reason
and faith presents itself and it is
always present it always presents itself
sooner or later even when we least
expect it
is this conflict not the best
justification of those who doubt the
deepening
it is not that doubt excludes deepening
it excludes only its sufficiency one can
say in opposition
if it is systematic out of the preceding
deepening that engenders this exclusion
this would justify the skepticism of
those whose belief stems from cowardice
to them we respond if people slaves of
their passions and desiring to flee them
embrace a faith because in it they see
their liberation
the faith that they embrace is not
deliverance but only the desire for
deliverance this vain faith gives an
illusion of life to things that are dead
for many men lie to themselves and lie
in order to give themselves courage
but hope is a virtue and those who
renounce it fall inevitably into
skepticism it is the actual life of
truth that prays and which obtains the
view of charity mal branch wrote
well then there are two types of faith
the faith of love and the faith of
desire he who loves gives he who desires
demands and those who believe in dead
things do not love them
they only desire them
this exclusion is the virtue of hope's
reason for being which blossoms in the
souls of those who do not let themselves
be brought down by life's difficulties
but who despite all that certain of the
fertility of their efforts beyond the
sadness that sometimes weighs very
heavily
make their faith a conquest by
enlivening it and fighting for it it is
only in this sense that a christian
philosophy is not only possible
but necessary
so here's mr blondel's response to mr
costelli
mr costelli's reflections bear not on
the problem that i set out but as he
explicitly notes on the way in which
miss mr jillson envisions envisages the
problem of christian philosophy from a
double point of view historical and
rationalist at the same time i do not
have to enter personally into that
debate the multiple difficulties that mr
costelli raises contribute more to
showing the interest he has in
envisaging the problem in a different
way than others have done they do not
touch on the positions in relation to
which i have located myself
the result even of mr costelli's
diversely convergent critiques is that
if we seek a solution on the terrain of
history and of concepts we are led to
mix two orders of questions in reality
different from each other
on the one hand we seek in the doctrines
of the past the traces of the christian
contribution in so far as revealed
teaching
is philosophically assimilable in the
form of rational concepts
so that the relation between christian
dogma and philosophical speculation is
confined within the ensemble of a system
of ideas composable with each other
making abstraction of all supernatural
and humanly inaccessible
[Music]
characters specifically human data
on the other hand
as mr costelli shows
a difficulty inevitably arises that we
cannot fail to recognize or eliminate
without making the very meaning of most
essential christian demands disappear
from the very viewpoint a philosophy of
concept sets itself within reason and
faith cannot coincide and it is the role
of reason
in the act of faith or the role of faith
in the
reasonable adherence to the revealed
truths
that becomes
or
that becomes incomprehensible it must
even be added that the historical
notional way in which the problem has
been envisioned
brings in its wake an inextricable
confusion between two problems extremely
important to distinguish and resolve
each for its own sake
without failing in this to recognize the
solidarity
connecting them together
the first of these problems is that of
the autonomy of a rational doctrine
developing its legitimate certainties in
an organism of truths of the natural or
metaphysical order and this without
compromising the reality of the
supernatural order and its demands which
neither repress nor wound reason but
complete it and satisfy it
the other problem is that of the
reasonable character intrinsic to the
adherence to faith without this
compromising the role of freedom or the
need for grace for the supernatural act
of faith
we see well enough the deep distinction
that exists between this use of reason
in the heart of religious belief and
that other use of rational speculation
for the completeness and
comprehensiveness
of the knowledge it can acquire about
objects falling under its competence
nobody will be able to it will be able
to justify the existence of a catholic
philosophy
except by extricating themselves from
these confusions
and putting themselves in a perspective
very different from that toward the
debate brought us a debate from which i
would like to free our readers the
service that mr castelli renders us
is to show us by his critiques in his
desiderata that the road that many have
gone down is an impasse
he leads us therefore to turning
ourselves back to the sole world that
leads somewhere
all right so now we have the comments of
mr jean devil vey
i do not wish to confine myself to
repeating here under other forms the
wish that i formulated in a letter
addressed to mr maurice blondel and that
he did me the great honor of reproducing
at the end of his presentation summary i
believe i will better bear wit will
better bear witness to the deep sympathy
with the thought of a philosopher who
has engaged all the strength of his soul
and philosophy by not holding myself to
the too easy position of an attempt at
agreement yet to come but by bringing
out several remarks about the very basis
of the problem
even if they must cause to arise the
sentiment of a current divergence
i give my full agreement to the
conclusions of mr blondel's method yes
the question ought to be examined and
with neither prejudice nor reticence my
reason for this is that is first that i
refuse to adhere to a mythical notion of
reason to regard that what we give this
name is a fixedly determined and
sufficient power that the human mind
sets to work in order to know all that
it belongs to it to know
i see there a varied and variable
ensemble on the common theme of certain
elementary useful means
of rational procedures serving to
illuminate experience a term that is
itself not susceptible of designating
something other than an acquired state
of illumination of
rational procedures develop themselves
coordinate themselves renew themselves
in time obtain effects diversely
inadequate but of a generally growing
value
i do not consider our human reason of
today
as radically distinct and different in
its most elevated forms from simple
sensible rationality but to be sure
from another point in the levels of
consciousness it would appear to some
mind as imperfect as sensible
rationality appears to us
complementary i discard any mythical
notion of fact understood as a fixed and
determined element of any rational
consciousness this term is applied
successively or confusedly to either
sensible perceptions concretized around
human functional interest biological
psychological or social
or
to abstractions
spontaneously or reflectively
constructed for the use of objectifying
analysis or aesthetic representation
irreducible to the two preceding types
or to states such as those of the mystic
affirming to have experienced their
immediate union with god
so that to be definitive fact cannot
receive a general signification
different from that which i attributed
above to experience
these points established denial of any
intimate connection between philosophy
and religious faith referred to
revelation by alleging a pretended
autonomy and philosophy rationally
drawing its knowledge from facts seems
to me
to be vain and arbitrary this cannot be
presented as a constant philosophical
demand but as a pretension specific to a
narrow and dare i say outmoded
positivism
but on the other hand
i feel the need to discuss and parallel
the signification of the term
supernatural revelation
opposed to that of the term rational
knowledge
the significations of these two terms
are correlative if i accepted
understanding rational knowledge
exclusively as knowledge of a nature
whose representation was exhausted in a
summary of necessary relations
connecting the determined facts the sort
of nature assumed by positivism
supernatural would doubtless signify
something foreign to that nature thus
rationally inconceivable but susceptible
nevertheless by some no less
inconceivable operation of being
displayed to the mind
and becoming the object of an
affirmation of existence supernatural
revelation understood in this sense is
radical miracle evident evident and
perfectly unintelligible at the same
time
is such a notion
real
or imaginary
does it offer some interest a thought
in any case it evaporates along with the
notion of rationality to which it's
opposed and which is only a falsified
interpretation of clarity of
an action and of the feeling of being
concentrates itself again in a
reflection that aims at total being and
tries to abolish the multiple points of
the objective surface from which these
rays are sent
for this region of clarity which may be
called from the name of its means of
generation rational consciousness what
signification will the term of
supernatural take
doubtless not that of something foreign
to the being that is that very clarity's
principle and end
it will therefore be able in the
interior of the luminous net to help
form the analytic starting point between
the objective spectacle a provisional
ensemble of abstractions to which it is
permitted to restrict the term nature
and the ontological source and end point
of the light of consciousness
how would the supernatural not
indivisibly arise for philosophy and for
religion
from what source if not from the most
interior of being would there come
supernatural revelation and what
philosophy unmutilated in its heart
would be repulsed by naming god the
living principle just as much as the
final object of its speculative effort
from the historical point of view i
think i see clearly the constant
continuity of religious forms and
philosophical forms whether it be in
mediterranean antiquity where the
religious forms and their most living
manifestations appear as forms of
intelligibility rationally exceeding the
brutality of sensible constructions and
where the philosophical forms that is
reflectively rational forms of all the
ages cannot hand over their full
signification to those who claim to cut
off their religious roots
or in the new judeo-christian religious
impulsion correlative to the general
dissolution of the greco-roman social
forms
from the apologetic point of view the
notion of revelation is offered
primitively under the main aspect of the
sensible miracle-breaking
functional perception but not of all
sensible miracles
rather only of those that witness to the
generative power of an intelligibly
conceived order
and it is offered more progressively
under the primary aspect of the manifest
inspiration of men of writings of
churches manifest that is evident to the
mind
whether by indubitable historical
reconnection to the miracle
or to the initial evidence
or whether it be by immediate
recognition and written thought or in
the speeches and acts of men or of the
church of the index of god who's been
conceived
and it is offered as well under the
simplified aspect of a mystical
communication whose authenticity ought
to be discerned by a very subtle
speculation
that rejects the false testimony of
analogous states and thus relates the
true communication to the intelligible
order on which prayer is grounded
all of these are aspects that forbid
separating revelation from rational
assessment
it remains to try to make precise the
difference and the relation of religion
and philosophy and the great genre of
spiritual vision for me to try that here
in the these lines of a letter would be
rash instead i might try to indicate
without providing any justification of
it the direction of my thought and to
satisfy what i believe to be a demand of
sincerity by letting be seen how it
seems to diverge from the perspectives
that mr maurice blondel's work has
powerfully illuminated for us mr blondel
has made an audacious and magnificent
effort to integrate all of the
philosophical rationality and all of
religion represented in the unique and
perfect form of the catholic religion
rational philosophy constituting a vast
foundation that receives its
indispensable crowning from the
essential revelations of faith
it is this product of integration that
he calls catholic
philosophy i conceive of a more intimate
fusion or rather a certain radical unity
in religion i see living human
spirituality
that is incarnated in the biosocial
organism of the human species it
emanates from the depths of being and
raises the life and man to the level of
the threshold of rational consciousness
of which religious representation is a
spontaneous production how can one
refuse to call it source divine and its
development providential carrying out
for the benefit of successive sketches
of rational vision and social
materialization but with the meaning of
an inspiration or if one prefers of a
constant aspiration of being through the
generations
this providential movement has nothing
uniform in its course nor in the
continuity of its contextual taking
place in the ponderous complexity of
sensible and noetic matter in the heart
of this movement of the growing mind
rational effort although subordinated to
the aspiration that it illuminates
reveals its destiny and plays a major
role i see philosophy consisting in the
cluster
woven around reflectively rational
effort a cluster that differentiates
itself by the providential movements
nudges to the heart and that there takes
on a growing though always relative
autonomy even when it comes to lose the
sense of its functional solidarity
but its real autonomy is capable of
growing to the degree only that
rationally reflective thought progresses
in the supernatural domain of being
so that it meshes in with the biological
and social movement of humanity
for the liberation of the mind in
relation to the body rejected by the
christian representation and the
eternity of a future life cannot also be
conceived by the most reflectively
rational thought except as limit and to
infinity
as to the present time it seems to me
characterized by a state of contraction
onto itself of the rational cluster
which pursues its own growth without
thereby benefiting or benefiting only a
little the living spirituality
whose most living and highest
established form doubtless not
independent of some prejudice deriving
from the spiritual race i am inclined to
see in the catholic religion the
consequence is that our moment already
many times secular is that of a certain
functional disunion painfully damaging
to the realization of spiritual life
these hasty notes permit i hope to make
a little more precise the meaning that
the wish for communion mr blondel was
willing to recall
takes in my mind
all right
mr blondel's response to mr devil vayne
i must warmly thank mr devil vey for
having opened to our reflections in two
different directions deep perspectives
that to be fully explored require more
space than i have here
in a first direction his penetrating
genetic analyses set us on guard against
an easy and frequent triple illusion
at the start he denounces the
superstitious use of the word and the
concept of reason than that of fact
finally that of revelation
in agreement with him for a long portion
of his trajectory and the way i will
soon indicate i admit however not being
able to stop there like him and draw a
conclusion it is very true that the
cyclical idea of a reason stabilized in
principles in notions in laws naveriater
is a myth not one of those that are
stimulating as a future an effective
idea even if a chemical one but as an
extrapolative stabilization that
according to mandy biren's expression
risks killing the inquiry becoming the
death of analysis and canonizing
laziness
still it should be said that outside of
the facts that we will have to critique
reason is pure a know me that outside of
the habits that set up positive data in
it and by it reason would have no
strength no light to go further ahead
to study the conditions implied in all
conscious perception and in all
reflective thought
above all should we say that reason
analyzing itself cannot determine the
springs that stimulate its exercise the
limits of its scope the aims that are
normatively its own that it cannot
dispense with and abstain from even when
it does
attain them
on this first point i believe more than
mr devil vey does in the intrinsic
value and the original nature of human
reason
in what concerns facts we willingly
recognize the difficulty of grasping
what we willingly call positive or
scientific data as if it were something
concrete for this is a matter of
decoupled aspects of extracts or
abstractions we raise to fragmentary
entities or to links in an indefinitely
extensible series
in a sense
it is an elaboration of thought that
gives us the facts just as much as they
are given and imposed on thought but
philosophy and science labor precisely
to distinguish and reconnect these
diplomatic aspects
and through this double labor our
certainties are purified and confirmed
by manifesting the profound realism of
reason itself which becomes conscious of
its own function
by leading us from rational forms all
the way up to an intelligible and
spiritual order
on this second point again my assessment
is that the witness of facts thanks to
critical and metaphysical analysis
possesses a solidity and admits of a
precision that does not leave
philosophical speculation a chance in
discernment of the realities most
important to man
if mr devil they preserves the role of
religious consciousness and divinizing
aspirations he still finds the idea of
revelation to be equivocal and
indefinable for the very reason that for
him the variability of reason and facts
leaves something indiscernible between
moral or religious consciousness drive
and what would be a contribution from
outside and from on high
in agreement with him in guarding myself
from pretended revelations and false
mysticisms i believe however
that the notion of a supernatural
intrinsically such historically proposed
and experimentally authentic
is conceivable verifiable and
assemblable
and as this is all that i have tried to
establish i can only leave it up to my
readers to decide the case
the second perspective by which mr devil
vey causes us to see with an accent of
moving generosity is in his conclusion
manifests the depth of the spiritual
crisis and the religious aspiration in
some of the most cultivated minds and
some of the highest souls of our times
this is the debate's entire vital knot
that would have to be undone and redone
if i needed to explain why
and how the religious drive while
arising from the very ground of nature
and of man has its point of beginning
and contact its constant spring its
progressive march
in the supreme end and in the
supernatural location
without which nothing of man's unique
and obligatory destiny would be set in
motion orient itself be illuminated get
anywhere
the flourishing of nature yes assuredly
but under the heat and the magnetization
of a double double gift that of the
spiritual nature that aims at possession
and at perfect beatitude
and that of grace accorded to all which
alone renders ascension possible up to
the divine terminus
these degrees to be distinguished and to
be carved out are not arbitrarily set
out nor seen simply from outside i have
tried to show that they are implied in
the entire movement of our thought with
the rigor of an internal diagnomism
that has nothing imprecise or merely
supplemental
to it
so that's the end of blondel's response
to devil vay
um
so
i want to say one thing before i i
address questions comments and stuff
like that
and it's kind of a little bit of
backstory about this so this book almost
didn't come about
in a way because um
catholic university of america press
in in their acquisitions process after
i'd done all these translations and
stuff wanted to pass on it and wanted to
pass on it because the person who they
had hired to do the review of the
translation focused in lazily only on mr
devil vay's
portion of the work
and devil vey as you can tell by you
know
the english translation of it
is not an easy writer as a matter of
fact i'm not even sure
how coherent his ideas truly are
and it was uh you know it's so it's sort
of like taking a
a symphony composed of many different
people's contributions and focusing in
on the one bit
that doesn't sound quite right as if
it's characteristic of the whole and the
reason why things actually this ended up
getting published is i wrote back an
angry email to the editor
and said you're you know
your reviewer is clearly off base here
and if you don't you know if if this is
the sort of crap that you're actually
going to have for reviews i'll just take
this elsewhere and publish it somewhere
else and then the editor looked over the
stuff and he's like oh yeah this this
reviewer actually was kind of kind of
lazy and focused in on the rowing things
devil vey is is somebody who i i was
never able to find much information
about
um
and his writing is very convoluted all
right so perspective philosophy says
feels platonic that
doesn't mean anything what feels
platonic and what do you mean by
platonic there's a you know there's the
platonism of plato there's the platonism
of middle platonism there's the
platonism of neoplatonism there's the
sort of slur word platonic from
nietzscheans or marxists or whoever else
so i don't know what that's actually
supposed to mean or what what it's
supposed to refer to
um we got to be specific in what we're
saying ricky says that is how you write
a peer review
yeah and that was something that um
you can say that one of the cool things
about the debates is that these people
read each other's stuff
took seriously what what the other
people had to say
reviewed things critically
made clear where they differed on things
um
i mean that's not the only thing to
recommend this this uh
these debates and and this
particular translation of of important
documents but
that is kind of a cool thing that comes
out of it you know
some of them were a bit uncharitable to
each other
um particularly blondel in relation to
jilson martin and mara tannengelson in
relation to
blondel um
but
on the whole
it was it was philosophers like doing
really solid work and that's that's one
of the reasons i wanted to
do the work of translating and
publishing this so
all right any other
questions comments spurred by this um
if not we'll have a
short session today
like i mentioned i'm a little bit worn
down i had to present at seven in the
morning
here uh for two hours
online for the brazilian epictetus
seminar that was going on
and i'm still in the process of
finishing out the semester
here
looking forward to some
down time for a little while
over the
holiday break
although there's
always lots of work to do
we'll resume um these these live
readings
um
[Music]
after uh the new year in part because
looking at the calendar
[Music]
yeah what was the justification
yeah so thursday is the 23rd things are
kind of winding down
um
and then uh the next thursday is the
30th again things are kind of winding
down getting ready for new year's and so
we'll start again on
on the uh the sixth
of january with more readings from this
and we'll finish those other two letters
the one from henry goulier the one from
joseph marshall and then we've got a
really interesting discussion going on
between
maurice blondell
jacques palliard and uh gaston berger so
all right well if there aren't any other
questions or comments i'm gonna
bid all of you a
good rest of the day wherever you happen
to be and i will see you next time